out of all mother Secrets I chose that
secret oh my
gosh read it out loud yeah read the
other person's out loud but oh God okay
okay all right I'm ready
[Music]
Queen I can go this person secret says I
am 25 years old and I have never had a
friend
uh I don't know friendships are hard to
come across honestly genuine friendships
but I hope you find one one
day it's emotional for
me no I'm going to keep going out of all
mother Secrets I chose that
secret I just lost a best friend
recently not not not not to death or
anything just I lost that friendship so
I'm just dealing with that yeah that's
why but I genuinely hope whoever if you
guys see this that you do find a genuine
friendship because when you do have a
genuine friendship they're
genuine every time I go to a party I
think I'm going to meet the love of my
life but it never happens I met my
husband at a party so it can happen just
keep
looking when I was young I drank so much
alcohol because I was sad and I wanted
to die
I made it such a habit that I am now
older and happy and can't quit I will
still probably die from it even though I
no longer want
to as far as alcoholism just keep
yourself busy like every second of every
day find a hobby find something that you
like and try to just drown the thoughts
out with that I've been I've been
through alcoholism it's not
fun sad oh my God I told my grandmother
that I love her I whispered in her ear
after she told me at age 75 that no one
ever told her that she is loved that was
rough that hit that hit dude cuz I don't
really get along with my family like
that and it's sad cuz I feel like family
should be everything but not for me I
guess once when I lived in student
housing I was woken up during the night
by some scuffling I was groggy looked
like some type of rat was messing with
my drafting papers so I caught it and
threw it in the dumpster across the
property oh next morning my roommate
wakes up telling me his pet hamster tofu
had escaped his cage overnight I didn't
know he even had a hamster and
immediately knew I had thrown out his
beloved pet I couldn't tell him the
truth and helped him look all around the
apartment for him when I had a chance I
looked for hours around the dumpster and
property but there was no way that
little hamsters should a chance out
there I eventually adopted a hamster of
my own to atone for that mistake and
gave him the best life I
could that's awful literally I'm vegan
and his name was
tofu that's so awful oh my gosh that
poor
hamster how do you not know that your
roommate has a pet
hamster like are you guys living in the
same room that's
awful oh no I don't even I want to
forget about that most of the
characteristics are I've adopted to
build my identity are only because I'm
terrified of being anything like my dad
and not because that's actually how I
want to be wow you have you have
complete autonomy over who you want to
be though um I think it's like very
cognizant of you to realize that there's
like different sources of where that can
come from but at the end of the day as
long as you're aware of that you can
always compare the person you are to the
influences that are around you and kind
of make decisions on whether or not you
know you want to let the people in your
lives influence the person that you are
or if you want to make something of
yourself I think this person's got a
good head on their shoulders uh thank
you for letting me read it I lied to the
guy I am seeing and told him I loved him
because he said it and I felt
bad maybe he needed to hear
that and as long as you're sharing love
it's okay don't feel
bad I don't hate life the past year I
have gone through the most awful roller
coaster in the history of my existence I
was depressed and took medication I've
convinced myself and everyone around me
that I wish I was never born that I wish
I could die right this second but I love
life I love sunsets and warm tea curling
up in blankets and holding hands being
heartbroken and being loved swimming
cycling dancing eating fruit and kissing
I was so good at convincing myself and
the ones around me that now I am afraid
to be judged if I admit how much I love
being a Human After
All yeah that was so good that was good
this is uh yeah seriously this is kind
of like poetry um hey uh person who
don't hate life don't be afraid to be
judged um I think all of those people
would love to know that you love being a
human after all I really do I think they
would love knowing
that I think so every secret I could
ever write down has to do with my dad
being awful to me I hate that the
deepest parts of me are still just him a
secret is so holy oneself and yet even
that is not
mine
wow no matter what after a formal
education and health policy and medical
sociology a decade of therapy impatient
treatment all of the work and additional
education endless support and
determination although I know the Deep
truth about bodies some days I still
want smaller
thighs there you go
desires are hard to let go
of my siblings and I had a horrible
childhood our parents are no longer in
our lives not that they were there to
begin with I wanted to be loved by a mom
and a dad more than anything in the
world I think about how alone I feel
every single day when I see dads hanging
out with their kids I wish I could run
up and hug them there was the sweetest
mom at the store with her daughter and
it brought me to tears looking at
something I have never had
I'm 30 years old and every day I hope to
find parents that will love me it's the
most painful secret I have ever lived
with G it makes me want to cry and it
makes me miss my parents who I've lost
cuz they were great parents the person
that wrote that I hope that you can find
expounding love in other areas of your
life and maybe one day you'll become a
parent and you can love your kids the
way that you never were loved by your
parents sometimes I'll drink just
because other people around me are I
have a incent need to relate to people
at all times to an extent that I forget
how to find enjoyment in myself
sometimes oh that's
sad I mean try try just a mocktail or
having a drink in your hand because then
you just it might just be the comfort of
holding something it you might not
actually need the alcohol or the drink
if you just have something in your hand
that might help you but I'm sorry that
you feel that
[Music]
way they say you need to learn to be
alone but when you are ready wake up
alone go to the movies alone go to the
museums alone you feel me go to the
shows alone go to bed alone I don't
really know how much alone I can learn
to
be we're better off by
ourselves I'll let y'all know a secret
though for real should I read one more
okay this is an internet one I
think okay I'm a guy that really enjoys
wearing women's panties and underwear
all sorts thongs too I do it partly
because I enjoy the great variety and
options as well as the comfort is way
better than what is offered for men for
mainstream options the only person who
knows is my significant other she loves
me the way I am but at times it bothers
her especially if she can tell I'm
wearing a thong or some other panty out
in public which can make me feel a bit
stifled one another reason I wear
panties is because I'm hopeful that if
someone were to see the Victoria Secret
tag or thong whale tail perhaps it will
make them chuckle and have a funny laugh
just for a moment I hope not not to
weird anyone out it's just a small
secret part of me that makes me feel
alive in a special way I'm only
human I'm
dead I know I this is
fantastic okay now I write a secret so I
can write my secret now I don't say it
though right like I just write it okay
cool they'll know it's me cuz it's a
Sandy one all right so just put it in
here I feel good I feel like I
contributed thank you it's nice I like
the idea that someone else is going to
read it feels good to like get it off
your chest a little bit kind of like an
anonymous therapy session it's cool that
like no one's going to know that it's me
and like I can just like let it go a
little bit more like in cm like without
weight you know and now I feel better
because I can speak about that many
years ago I I can do I I can't talk
about it because I was going to trouble
with me and yes I I feel better
now is that all
okay
hi everyone thank you for watching I'll
be posting bonus footage from this
episode on my patreon that means more
answers and extended cuts of each answer
if you want to see it you can sign up
I'll have it linked in my description
and if I ever do follow-ups on the
people you see in this episode that'll
be on my patreon as well thank you guys
for watching I love you all and I'll see
you next
[Music]
time